Hello, viewer.
I hope you're as excited as we are
about Patisserie Week.
I love patisserie.
I love tiny French cakes.
Smaller, the better.
I like them so small you can
only see them under a microscope.
I've written a song about patisserie.
- Wanna hear it?
- No.
- Gonna stop you there.
- Why?
I found it needlessly surreal.
- Was up all night writing that.
- Should've gone to sleep.
Welcome to
The Great British Baking Show.
Biff.
Oh!
- With a place in the final at stake...
- Come on.
...the bakers must
produce perfect patisserie...
Concentration station.
...with an elegant
French signature...
Hermine says, "savarin"
and I go, "sav-rin."
- ...a bewildering technical...
- Makes no sense.
I don't have a logical brain.
...and as temperatures
in the tent soar...
It's getting hot again.
...a scorching showstopper...
Please be good. Please be good.
...guaranteed to cause a meltdown.
Doesn't look set inside.
Don't even wanna carry on.
Is this gonna look like a complete mess?
Oh, my God.
What a nightmare.
I'm looking forward to this week.
Patisserie is an exciting thing.
It's not home baking any more,
it's perfection, precision,
that's patisserie.
I'm not feeling too confident.
I'm just a home baker,
so this is out of my comfort zone.
It would be a killer
to go out just before the final.
I'm feeling more nervous
that it's the semifinals
than the fact that it's Patisserie Week.
But I think we're all worried about
Hermine because she is patisserie.
She's really good at what she does.
It's supposed to be
the week I enjoy the most,
but I need to make it to the final,
so pressure's on.
Hello, kids. Congratulations,
you've made it to the semifinal.
Whoo!
Which means that three of you
are gonna be in the final
and one of you is gonna
have to spend the rest of their life
as Prue's live-in butler.
Imagine that.
Ma'am, your buttered crumpet.
Oh, it's not worth the calories.
Thank you, ma'am.
The judges would like you
to make 12 identical patisseries
using pâte à savarin,
which is a yeasted enriched dough.
Your savarin...
...can be any shape or flavour you like,
but once baked, should be soaked
in a syrup of your choosing.
This is the semifinal, kids,
so the judges are looking for high-end
and they want an exquisite finish.
You have two hours and 45 minutes.
- On your marks...
- Get set...
Bake.
We're in the semifinal.
This is pretty awesome.
Stressed.
I doubt that many
home bakers do patisserie.
Not something I've really done before.
Patisserie is one
of the hardest challenges.
It's neat, it's exquisite, it's elegant.
Some may not know
what a savarin is,
but think rum baba.
That base is a savarin.
It's a yeasted enriched dough
baked and cooked in a mould.
Hermine says, "savarin"
and I go, "sav-rin."
Doing the old
savarins this week, ain't we?
Shove 'em in the oven, the old savarins.
It's all about the proving,
the softness of the sponge
and beautiful, delicate flavours.
That's what patisserie's all about.
Almost the worst challenge
is they're baking in a heatwave
which means that proving times
will probably be shorter.
They ought to watch that.
Gonna be interesting to see
who steps up to the plate
and creates something
that deserves its place in a patisserie
anywhere in the world.
But any of our four bakers
could go through to the final.
I think these four are as good
as we've ever had. I really do.
Strange dough to work with.
It needs to be pipeable.
If done right, it bakes beautifully.
Normal dough,
you can knead it. Can't touch that.
It's very, very wet.
Just looking for a really
silky smooth, stretchy dough
and I'm pretty much there.
- Hi.
- Hello.
Hello, Prue.
Tell us about your savarin.
So I'm doing a baba au rhum.
Oh, lovely. I do like a rum baba.
And I'm gonna glaze it
with, erm, an apricot jam
to kind of give it the shine.
Hermine, this should be your day.
This is such a classic French thing.
I hope I can deliver.
Hermine's chosen
to make rum babas for her savarin.
She's keeping things traditional,
filling them with vanilla crème pat
and decorating with piped Chantilly cream
and tempered chocolate.
You've won Star Baker twice.
Nobody else has done that.
You feeling confident
going into the final?
I don't want that
to give me a big head so...
- You've had a handshake, as well.
- No.
But then you can let things
like that distract you, isn't it?
Exactly. Don't think about that.
Just concentrate on today, relax,
- do your best.
- Yes.
Say "apricot" for us one more time?
Apricot.
- That's a handshake.
- Thanks, Hermine.
You're welcome.
But Hermine's got competition
in the battle of the babas.
She just keeps copying me.
Someone's gonna have
to say something to her.
Hermine, you learnt all you know
from me, right?
- Yeah. See?
- I did.
Laura's giving
her rum babas a tropical twist
with a filling of poached pineapple,
kiwi, and passion fruit.
To finish, she's adding pipettes of syrup
to inject an extra kick
of rum into her bake.
Tell us about your dough.
A fairly standard savarin dough.
I used fresh yeast
'cause it gives a nicer rise.
Really?
Why do you think fresh yeast is better?
Er...
You think it gives a better rise?
- Just say yes.
- Yes.
Oh.
That was horrible.
Like you're being interrogated.
I was sweating, weren't you?
- "Why do you use that yeast?"
- Don't let him get in your head.
He's really good at it.
He's got eyes like the nightwalker.
Make you doubt yourself.
To create a savarin to savour...
In for the first prove.
...the bakers
need to prove their dough
long enough to achieve
a light, open texture.
The whole point of it is
you make it like a bread-type cake
and then you soak it in syrup.
All the flavour comes from the syrup.
The rum is spiced but I'm adding
some spices as well to the mix.
While Hermine and Laura
are aiming to perfect a French classic...
Yum.
...Dave is taking
his savarin all the way to Mexico.
Tequila.
Dave's savarins
will be soaked in honey tequila
before being set on
a mango-passion fruit curd
and crowned with a honey
and cocoa Chantilly cream.
Mango, passion fruit,
chocolate and tequila.
And tequila, yes.
Hmm.
Quite a mix.
You think you'll get into the final?
It's in sight, but there's
tough competition here.
I'm just gonna try my best.
I tell you what, Dave, you are
looking so much more confident.
- Thank you.
- Different from when we first met you.
- Good luck.
- Right, cheers.
- Thank you. Tequila.
- Tequila. Come on.
Now you're talking.
Jiminy Christmas.
While Dave, Laura,
and Hermine are all banking on booze...
Whenever I make syrup,
I always add my alcohol last
because I don't want the alcohol
to evaporate too much.
I want it quite strong,
trying to make Prue happy.
...to meet the demands
of Patisserie Week...
I'm not overcomplicating it today.
I wanna get something out that's
really clean and looks professional.
...Peter's chosen
to keep a clear head.
Not soaking it in alcohol.
In here, I've got elderflower cordial,
lemon juice, water, and sugar.
I don't drink very much myself
so I thought, we'll go
for a teetotal savarin.
I'm the one that goes to the club sober,
leaves after an hour.
I'm really boring.
He may think he's a square,
but Peter's hoping rectangular savarins
will help him pass this exam.
He's soaking them in an elderflower syrup
before finishing with elderflower
and strawberry crème diplomats.
I would like to see the old Peter today.
We've got a bit of heat in the tent.
You just gotta concentrate,
ignore that and just don't make mistakes.
Do you like that advice?
"Don't make mistakes."
It sounds...
- As easy as that.
- It's so simple.
- We can do it.
- Thank you.
Don't make mistakes, yeah?
That's the plan.
I'm gonna bring back week-one Star Baker
and show them what I can do.
That's your yeasted enriched dough.
- Is it proving now?
- It is. Wanna see the best bit?
- Go on.
- Imagine it's Paul's face.
Oh! Really?
- And then you go, boof.
- Oh, poor Paul. Oh, my Lord.
- Wanna do it?
- Okay, here we go.
- Go for it.
- Biff.
Oh!
- You can keep that.
- Wow.
I'm gonna sell this on eBay.
With the first prove finished...
I'm gonna
get this into a piping bag
and you'll see how we can
pipe such a substance.
...the savarins
can begin to take shape.
It's not easy
to pipe because it's quite elastic
but I want it to be consistent.
I'm just making
each one even in weight.
They should all rise identically.
That's what I'm hoping for.
Right, so, that's me done.
I've gotta prove these
until they double in size.
But the savarin might be
ready sooner than expected.
'Cause it's getting really hot now,
could be as little as 30 minutes.
We have to wait and see.
High temperatures in the tent
mean the bakers risk
over-proving their dough...
It had 30 minute during practice.
I'll give it the same
and then have a look.
...resulting in
flat, collapsed cakes.
They're not
gonna buy rustic this time.
It's gotta be perfect.
But stop proving too soon
and they'll rise too quickly in the oven,
causing them to tear.
So warm in here.
Bakers, you have 4,950 seconds left.
Is that real?
Matt, how long do we actually have?
Hmm?
- Oh, you're halfway through.
- Thank you.
With their dough rapidly rising...
- Did you try and work that out?
- No.
...they'll need every second
to create their fillings and toppings.
Mmm.
It's about balance with flavours.
Quite a lot going on with the rum,
fruit, the dough, everything,
so the Chantilly cream
just breaks it up a bit.
The savarin is gonna be set
on a mango and passion fruit curd.
So, like a fruity custard.
I'm making a crème pat.
I'm worried that they might say
it's simple, but it is a classic.
A classic is simple.
Ever seen Babar?
Yes, when I was young.
I still watch it now.
I love Pingu. I watch Pingu.
Do you ever watch Pingu?
- No.
- Love Pingu.
Pingu.
Ooh, yeah, they're definitely well-proved.
They've really risen
but they're all even.
Think that's proved.
So, they're going in
for 15 minutes at 175.
I think that is quite hot,
but it's for a quick bake.
I'm baking them for 14 minutes.
Ten to 12-ish minutes until they're
nice and dark golden brown on top.
Look at you go.
- You're so laid-back.
- Am I?
Think you're gonna win this?
Who knows. It's in
the hand of the universe.
I love that you trust the universe.
What about old good flavours Laura?
- Gonna have to...
- Aren't you?
Gonna have to... Bang!
- Oh.
- You do what you've
- gotta do in this business.
- No, that's not nice.
It's gotta be a proud win.
Universe win.
They look golden.
Keep them in for a few more minutes.
They're rising nicely.
Maybe talking too early.
They're looking
very golden and lovely.
Gonna make sure that they're not under.
I'd rather them be
slightly over and a bit drier.
Right, I need to take these out.
Yeah, they're cooked.
Looking good. Puffed up nicely.
Hopefully nice, light and airy.
Feeling good. Really good.
They're the colour you want?
Yes, they are.
Probably Paul will say they're too dark...
Say that you've modelled them on his tan.
I dare you.
You might not get a Hollywood handshake,
but you'll get one from me.
From the look of them,
I've underproved it.
Oh. Dear, dear, dear.
I'll do another batch.
This is the semifinal,
so I do want it to be perfect.
Let's start again.
Okay, bakers,
you've only got one hour left.
Time flies when you're having fun.
Let's try again
and see this time.
I mean, the weather's not helping.
Hopefully, this one will be all right.
While Hermine's babas
are starting at the beginning...
This time, I'll just give it 15 minutes.
...the rest of the bakers
will now find out
if theirs passed the final test.
Just dip them in.
The whole point is to saturate it.
So you want no dry spots.
It just holds onto
as much syrup as it can.
Get down.
Soaking them
for 30 seconds each side.
They should soak up enough syrup.
I'll be soaking them for four minutes,
which, for tiny things, is a long soak.
But they're gonna be absolutely bursting
with this lovely syrup.
Only concern is if they hold their shape.
Bakers, you have 30 minutes left.
Was that okay?
Gonna get them in now.
Don't take long to cook.
Hopefully, we're good this time.
These need to go in the fridge
to firm up and set more
and then the savarin will sit on the curd.
I need to focus now 'cause
this is the tough bit, the fancy bit.
Concentration station.
I'm gonna
get my decoration ready.
So as soon as I soak my savarin,
I'm ready to go.
The mango curd's set nicely.
Happy with that.
They look pretty uniform.
Deep breath.
These are also popping off.
I'm just gonna pick the best ones.
Okay, bakers, you have five minutes left.
What? Oh, God,
my hands are shaking so much.
I need to make 12 mango flowers.
It's just really fiddly to roll these up.
I wanna make sure
I get this absolutely bang on.
This one is leaning.
These are little pipettes
to just get a bit of extra syrup.
Okay, bakers, your time is up.
Please step away from your bakes.
I did patisserie.
I can't believe I've just done that.
Where are yours?
- In the freezer.
- Oh, are they?
The bakers' soaked savarins
will now be judged by Prue and Paul.
Hello, Hermine.
- Hello, Prue, Paul.
- Hey, Hermine.
They look really interesting
- and very elegant.
- Mmm.
- And quite modern.
- I love the pipe work on them.
There's a little irregularity
with the colour on these.
Let's have a look.
I love the little tempered chocolate disk
on the top.
I quite like the flavour.
Alcohol's just enough to give it a kick.
The Chantilly and crème pat
work beautifully, nice and creamy
and the texture's all good.
The savarin itself,
it's slightly under-proofed.
The air holes inside are very tight,
they should be a little more open.
- I find it a little tough...
- Mmm.
...and too bread-like. Flavour's lovely.
- Thank you.
- I love that cream.
- Well done.
Well done.
At first glance,
I think they're really pretty.
I love the combination of colours.
They're golden brown.
They really do look scrumptious.
They're a little bit messy on the icing.
Likewise with the actual bake.
They all look different sizes.
That one looks bigger than this one.
Let's have a look.
- So what's in the little pipette?
- Rum syrup.
- Squeeze and it'll get more?
- Yeah.
That's a lovely, light sponge.
That's beautiful.
Got some spice in there?
- I put star anise and cinnamon.
- Cinnamon? Mmm.
You slightly overdid it
with some of the spices.
- Okay.
- It's little things.
You're like a rough diamond.
Need polishing up a little bit.
- This is a very good rum baba.
- Thank you.
Nobody would send it back in a restaurant.
I probably would. Just to meet the chef.
Oh, no, stop.
- A compliment from Paul.
- See? Lowered your hopes,
raised them at the end.
- Well done.
- Thank you.
They look unusual.
They're different. Bold, strong colour.
Ripped it there
getting it out of the mould.
- Yeah.
- I think they look really sensational
and fun.
Well, the texture of the cake is so light.
It's almost impossible
to get it onto the fork.
- I think it's lovely.
- Mmm. So do I.
I don't get
the curd sitting at the bottom.
- I know it's a design thing...
- Yeah.
...but I would've put that inside
and topped it with chocolate.
But, you know, the thing that surprises me
is I thought
you had too many flavours in this.
- It's not. It really works.
- Really, thank you.
- Cheers.
- There you go.
I think they look very neat
and very uniform.
It looks like they're quite soaked,
which is good.
- That looks light.
- Lovely.
Look at that.
I didn't think I was going to like
a savarin without any booze in it.
- But it's delicious.
- Fantastic.
- Mouth-watering.
- Yeah.
You got such a nice texture to that.
Very open inside,
which is classic savarin.
All I can say, Peter...
- Oh, wow.
- Welcome back to the tent.
Thank you so much.
And welcome back to the Peter standard.
He told me I wasn't allowed to clap
when someone gets a handshake, but...
Well done.
Ba-boom. Yeah! Handshake.
Usual comments, tastes nice, looks a mess.
Getting a bit bored of that, to be honest.
It's disappointing.
But hey, you win some, you lose some.
I'm feeling overwhelmed now.
This is incredible
that I managed to do so well.
So going into the technical,
I'm going in with confidence.
It's gonna definitely be
a tough technical, I think.
Yeah. Bring it on.
For the bakers, the pressure
of Patisserie Week is about to rise
as they face their toughest technical yet.
Bakers, it's time
for your semifinal technical challenge.
And this one has been set by Paul.
Paul, any words of advice?
It's quite methodical, this challenge.
It's about precision.
- Has he finished?
- Well, he went on for quite a long time.
- For him.
- Yeah.
As ever, this technical challenge
will be judged blind,
so we're gonna have to ask
these two to pop out of the tent.
Off you go.
- Where they going?
- It's all right. Calm down.
Where they going?
- They'll be back.
- I don't want them to go.
Pull yourself together.
- Finished?
- No.
Okay, I'm finished.
The judges would like you
to make a Danish cornucopia,
a traditional Danish celebration cake
otherwise known as the Horn of Plenty.
Now, the classic horn shape
is achieved by stacking rings of dough.
Your dough needs to be firm
on the outside, but chewy on the inside.
You have two hours and 15 minutes.
- Bake.
- On your marks.
Get set.
Danish cornucopia?
No, I've never heard of one.
I can't really think
of what it's gonna be.
I've never even
heard of it before, so...
All my guess, really.
I need to read the instructions
to get an idea
of what it's gonna look like.
But no, it's not a clear picture
in my head right now.
Never heard of it. Never eaten it.
Never seen it. It's gonna be fun, innit?
Paul, Danish cornucopia,
what's all this about?
It's a perfect challenge,
I think, for the bakers.
It's got no flour in it.
It's basically ground almonds in there.
Once you've made the dough,
they've got to divide it up
and then shape it.
Shape it into a round, bit like a cigar,
just taper the ends so they bind together.
When you do the cigar shape,
you encourage a little bit of a slope.
So as you piece them all together,
the slope begins to curve
and that's how you get that shape.
- They're thicker in one side.
- Exactly.
If they don't,
they'll end up being very flat.
And you won't get that depth
which you see here
in the Horn of Plenty all the way along.
Do you wanna try some of my horn?
- You can have that piece.
- Thank you.
This is lovely and chewy and very almondy.
You've got this gorgeous,
soft, chewy almond filling
with this light, crispy exterior.
You've got
so many different textures in there.
I'm sure we're gonna get
some bakers in there
who'll struggle with the shape,
but I hope they don't struggle
with the overall texture.
Paul, I think it's a really good challenge
and especially for the semifinal.
Not easy, very delicate,
absolutely delicious.
Right, where am I? Oh.
Just says, "Make the dough."
Icing sugar, egg whites,
almond extract and ground almonds.
Never made a dough without flour before.
I've never seen
a biscuit like this before
and I've certainly never baked one before.
I understand what he means by
crisp outside, chewy in the middle.
It's kind of like an amaretti biscuit
that's not quite baked.
We're gonna have to work fast,
there's lots of shaping to do
and we've got two hours fifteen,
which is not a long time.
- Hello, Noel.
- How did you know it was me?
You're still elated
from the handshake, aren't you?
It was like this.
Whoo. And then you went, "Aah."
And then did you get on his shoulders?
Did you kiss him?
Did you get his number at least?
That was your moment.
He softens for a minute.
You've got like a window to get his email,
get his number, try his clothes on.
That'll do.
I've made the dough now.
So the next step
is to start shaping this.
Gotta use these templates.
"Measure 18 grams of dough
and shape it into a cigar shape."
"Press the ends together..."
"...overlapping by
half a centimetre to form a ring
that's approximately
half a centimetre the height..." No.
Gotta get my head round this.
"Press the ends together
overlapping by one centimetre."
Er...
This is like rocket science.
Makes no sense.
I just read that and I have no idea
what I actually read,
so I'll reread that
probably about six times.
This is literally my worst nightmare.
I don't have a logical brain.
I can't do this.
I think I know what I'm doing.
Where I'm joining the two bits of dough,
it's gonna be thin.
So it's gonna be like a circle,
thick at one end, thin at the other.
And I'm guessing like that.
Right, got it.
How's it going?
Stressful, innit?
I just don't have a logical brain.
This is literally my worst fear
of not being able to present anything
on the technical.
But you are gonna
present something, aren't you?
Yeah.
You can do it. There's something in you
that'll get you to the next step
because if there wasn't,
you wouldn't be here.
- You're gonna smash it.
- Thank you.
Don't literally smash it.
That'd be a disaster.
- I'm quite clumsy. It could happen.
- If you literally smash it.
- Bless you. You're the best.
- See you later.
Thank you, Matt.
Oh.
I love him.
So I can start shaping.
I'm going with that.
When you join it together,
you get a smaller and a thicker side.
- This will have to do.
- Like that?
I feel good about that one.
- This is number two.
- Eleven in total, there should be.
One, two, three, four, five, six,
seven, eight, nine, ten, eleven.
If I achieve this,
I'm gonna have the biggest glass of gin...
and sambuca chasers.
Obviously, it all comes down to the bake.
Going in.
Gonna check that in about ten minutes.
I'm gonna put them in for 15 minutes,
but I'll check it after ten.
I think
I'm gonna freestyle and see.
Forgot to put the oven on.
I think we'll whack it up a bit.
I'm just gonna do my chocolate.
Save some time, be a bit strategic.
"Place a sheet of acetate
over the template provided
and pipe chocolate scrolls."
Melting my chocolate.
- Hi.
You okay?
Yeah.
Shall I get on your shoulders?
It's all right.
You get on my shoulders. Trench coat.
Your head out the top.
Buttons pop open,
Horn of Plenty comes out.
Yes or no?
Right, I'll get that stuff ready.
Boulangers.
Vous êtes demi... the way through.
Was that okay, Hermine?
No.
Gonna leave them in.
The more they're baked,
the stronger
they have the chance of being.
Going in for another ten minutes.
It's nearly there.
They're gonna have to go in.
I'm sure I had another timer.
Oh, well,
we'll just... Until they're brown.
"Spoon the chocolate into a piping bag."
"Pipe chocolate scrolls."
I don't mind doing this stuff,
it's quite nice.
It gets better as I go along, I think.
They look brilliant.
Ooh, that one's a bit wonky.
Whoo.
I think it's about time
to come out now.
I'm pulling them now.
Quite sort of golden.
They don't look burnt.
No point not being happy,
so let's stay happy.
They look a bit cracked.
Are they supposed to be cracked?
No, they need a little longer.
Just do a couple of minutes at a time
because that extra minute...
You can go over too much.
Mmm. Brilliant.
All cracked.
It's the right colour.
Any more, it would've burnt.
So next step is to make royal icing.
Whisking together
icing sugar and egg whites.
That's gonna be decorating
the biscuits themselves.
"Pipe zigzag patterns
onto the cooled rings and leave to set."
Good with icing. Can do icing.
Good start.
It's very messy, isn't it?
- I don't love that one.
- Bit scruffier now.
Well, that'll do.
Ah. Look at that. What a day.
Bakers, you've got half hour left.
It's not long.
"Step 12, make caramel."
- The caramel will glue it together.
- So I need 200 grams of sugar.
I'm gonna do my caramel.
I'm just gonna do it by eye.
I need this to be liquid
whilst I'm sticking things together,
but have some tackiness to it
so that it's gonna bind and set on there,
not just run out everywhere.
It's crystallised.
Caramel just never goes right for me.
Gonna start making the old tower of doom.
"Dip the bottom flat side
of ring number eight in the caramel
and place it on top of ring nine
so that they are joined base to base."
- Do you want me to say it?
- That might be helpful.
"Repeat the ring by ring process
while gently supporting the horn
to each ring."
Right.
I have to stick this and leave to set.
Right. That'll do.
It's not the prettiest of jobs.
It's stuck.
Sugar.
That's gonna be on the bottom anyway,
so they won't see it.
Bakers, you have five minutes left.
- This is dangerous.
- This is a bit crazy.
I'm not convinced
about what I'm doing here.
It's a bit leany, isn't it? Oh, well.
I wouldn't say it's the most
horn-like thing I've ever seen.
And then, I'm supposed
to stick the horn to the stand.
That feels very precarious.
Supposed to be like that?
That's how you know it's a horn, right?
Bakers, you have one minute left.
- All right.
- I'm sticking the chocolate scrolls on.
Oh, gosh. It's not gonna stand,
it's just too hot.
I can't peel them off.
Oh, my God. Still not cool enough.
Lordy...
I'm just gonna pipe over them.
Try and swirl it on.
Not sure if that's what they want,
but it's what they'll get.
My face says it all.
Bakers, your time is up.
Please bring your Horns of Plenty
down to the front
and place them behind your photographs.
Horrible challenge. Worst one yet.
I thought the matcha pancakes were bad.
It's an abomination, that is.
Prue and Paul are looking
for beautifully decorated cornucopia
in a classic horn shape.
I should've looked around.
Crispy on the outside
and soft and chewy inside.
Let's start with this one,
which is, erm...
Stop it, Paul.
It has no chocolate on it.
It should've been sitting more like that.
In which case,
it was the right shape.
The graduation
of the rings are there to the top.
I think you might break
your teeth on that.
- Hugely overbaked. Bone dry.
- Yes.
- Shame.
- Lovely flavour, though.
- I love that flavour.
- Hmm. That almond's lovely.
Right.
I'm sure that chocolate was...
- Standing up at one point.
- Yeah.
The icing's much nicer.
The graduation's okay
but there's no horn shape to it.
Little ones are overbaked,
top ones aren't.
You can't bake them all at the same time
- because they're different sizes.
- The fat ones are good.
- Hmm.
- Chewy.
- Neat. And they have the chocolate on 'em.
- Hmm.
Moving on. This is a bit of a mess.
Chocolate's gone all over the place,
- but the royal icing's terrible.
- Gone all over the place.
The colour of the rings
are all over the place.
That does look as if the baker
just didn't understand at all
what they were trying to do.
- Hmm.
- Almost raw.
- Like marzipan.
- Hmm.
There's been issues with that one.
Last one, we have a nice shape here.
They do look overbaked, though.
But there is chocolate on there.
- It is fairly neat.
- The icing's not good,
- because...
- No.
The whole idea of the icing
is to come down the sides
so that you can see it.
The flavour of that one's okay.
It's softer.
Paul and Prue will now rank
the Horns of Plenty
from worst to best.
In fourth place, we have this one.
Laura, almost everything
was wrong with this.
It did look like a mess.
Funnily enough, it was the only one
that was underbaked.
It was not your finest hour.
In third spot, this one.
David, they were a little bit solid.
- Yeah.
- All the way through.
In second place is this one. Who's that?
- Me.
- Hermine, this was so nearly there.
The decoration was really awful
but it was nicely baked,
and the right shape.
- Thank you.
- So in first spot is this one.
Peter, you forgot to put the horn shape
but they were delicious.
The look of them with the icing,
you even managed to do some nice little
swirls of chocolate on there as well.
Well done.
That's not been a bad day. Yeah.
But I don't wanna be complacent.
There's only four of us,
and anything can happen.
I'm really, really happy.
I can't complain, and Peter deserves it.
He's really good with detail,
which I'm not particularly,
so you can't take that away from him.
Third isn't too great in technical.
It's getting tougher as we go along,
but I had a good signature,
so I'm comfortable going
into the showstopper tomorrow.
Glad that's over.
It's not ideal,
but there's always tomorrow.
Gonna have to smash that.
There's just
the showstopper challenge left
before Prue and Paul decide
who's destined for Star Baker
and who will miss out
on a place in the final.
Hello bakers, welcome back.
It's time for your semifinal
showstopper challenge.
Today, Paul and Prue
would like you each to make a cube cake.
This should be comprised
of at least 25 mini cube-shaped cakes.
This is all about precision.
So the cubes need to be sharp
and uniform and very neat.
We're looking for an exquisite finish.
Your mini cakes can be
flavoured and decorated however you like.
And you can use non-edible supports
to help stack the layers.
But you will get extra points
if the whole thing is edible.
I'm on a diet
so I'll just eat the supports.
You have four and a half hours,
which seems like a lifetime.
- On your marks...
- Get set...
Bake.
One last challenge
before the potential final.
I'm just gonna have fun today.
Bake from the heart
and what will be, will be.
This is right up your street.
If you can't pull yourself
into the victory spot today,
- there's something wrong.
- Let's see what happens.
We've set the bakers a four-
and-a-half hour, gruelling, hot challenge.
And they have to make
a cube cake, straight edges, flat sides.
Think Rubik's Cube.
And in Patisserie Week,
we are looking for that precision,
that artistic flair,
and obviously, their baking skill.
This is a sponge cake.
And sponge has to be,
as always, beautifully flavoured
and beautifully textured.
Inside that sponge,
we'd like to see something like a mousse
or a melted chocolate or a ganache.
The four bakers are amateurs.
I want to see them pushing themselves
into that world of professionalism.
I think there's going to be
a real fight to get into the final,
and they need to fight for it.
- Hello.
- Morning.
Tell us about your cube cake.
I'm making a chocolate,
raspberry and pistachio cube cake.
- Yes. My favourite.
- Erm...
Magic. Erm...
We've got the three flavours
running through the entire cake.
I've got three different sponges,
mousses and glazes.
Wow. Clever.
Peter's going big
to avoid going home
with the tent's most ambitious cube cake,
made up of three types of cube.
Each will contain a different combination
of chocolate, raspberry
and pistachio sponge,
mousse and mirror glaze.
- It sounds wonderful.
- It does.
- That's a lot to do.
- So cracking on.
It is. Yeah, good luck.
Thank you.
I promise I won't disturb you at all.
Except you know I will.
The strategy for today
is to go out hard and fast,
so that by the end, I'll have time
to get that patisserie precision
that the judges are looking for.
It's gone well in practice.
While Peter's hoping
practice makes perfect,
for one baker, today's showstopper
will be a step into the unknown.
There's been a change of plan.
When I practised, it didn't go quite well.
So everything
I'm doing today is literally...
- New.
- ...new.
When did you decide to change your recipe?
- I wrote it yesterday morning.
- Yesterday?
Hermine's gambling everything
on a cube cake made up
of two different varieties,
both featuring her favourite flavours,
coffee and praline,
and cherry and chocolate.
They sound delicious.
- If it works, that'll be amazing.
- Very good luck.
Thanks.
- Sometimes, you have to take risks.
- True.
- Fortune favours the bold. Good luck.
- Thank you.
Not only must the bakers' sponges
pack plenty of flavour...
I always add a bit of coffee
in my chocolate sponge
so it brings the flavour out.
...texture must be spot-on, too.
I'm making my pistachio friand.
It's gonna be like a frangipane.
Very moist, very soft.
Always thinking about textures.
They're really important, I think.
It's not just about flavour.
Deliciously delicate, yet able
to hold their shape when layered.
This is the joconde sponge,
so that's just gone in at 190
for 12 minutes.
Today, I'm gonna be making
a chocolate cube cake.
I love chocolate, so this is just
to celebrate all things chocolate.
As well as chocolate sponge
and mousse, Dave's cubes will also contain
either a white, milk
or dark chocolate liquid caramel centre,
but with temperatures in the tent rising,
is Dave risking a meltdown?
- It's gonna be hot today.
- I know it's gonna be hot today, yeah.
Try to get most of it done
before the heat starts rising.
- Good luck.
- Yeah. Cheers.
That's for my praline mousse.
Don't have a clear vision at the moment,
so it's just keep going and don't stop.
With so many elements to juggle...
This is for
my chocolate hazelnut mousse.
...the bakers can't relax
for a second.
I always listen to my cakes
and hear them bubble.
If they bubble too much, they're not done.
If they don't bubble at all,
they're overbaked.
The smallest lapse
in concentration...
I've done that wrong.
...could spell disaster.
I meant to split the cream.
Heat half, and whisk half.
- Hello.
- Hello, vampire.
That's strong booze you've got going
on there. Whew!
- This is for Prue.
- What is it?
Kirsch. Yeah.
She might require
a little shot of that on the side
if you really wanna blackmail her.
A jug. Jug of kirsch.
Put lots of kirsch on.
If you're gonna do it, do it.
I'm doing a Black Forest gâteau-
inspired cube cake.
I like the flavours,
the dark chocolate and cherries.
They work nicely together.
It's one of my dad's favourite things.
This one's for him.
Although Laura's cake is made up
of just one type of cube,
each contains five layers,
including a biscuit crumb,
chocolate sponge, two mousses
and whole cherries.
All decorated
in a dark chocolate mirror glaze.
- I'm looking forward to this one.
- Good.
It's one of my favourite cakes.
And it's sort of important
that you do it really well, Laura.
Yeah, it's one of my favourite things
that I've, like, made.
I'm really proud of it.
Good. That's the spirit.
- Excited.
- Hope you like it.
I already like it.
I haven't even ate it yet.
- Ate it?
- And I already like it.
Thank you.
I'm confident with the flavours
of this one,
it's all about the setting time.
That's the big concern with the mousse,
that it doesn't set.
I'm using gelatin. It's got
two and a half leaves in each
of the mousse-es, moussi... meesse.
It's a delicate balance
with the gelatin
'cause you need it to set
but if you put too much in,
then it'll just be rubbery.
That's not very nice.
'Cause I'm not really
following a recipe,
I don't even know
if the quantities are all right.
Hopefully, this whole concoction
will work.
Easy on the gelatin. Easy.
You know exactly how many to use,
don't you?
I mean, I eat sheets of it as a snack.
- Fancy one?
- But not everyone's like me.
I used to wear boots from the '70s
made out of gelatin.
In hot weather, I'd get shorter.
That's looking good.
Does look nice,
I wanna eat it just like it is.
Right, how's this going?
Caramel's a big part of the cube cake,
so it needs to go right today.
I've still got my biscuit to make
for the cube cake stand
so I'm just gonna start prepping that.
This is gonna be
my cherry mousse.
Hopefully, it sets nicely.
I feel I'm behind.
It's crystallised. I just don't know
what it is with this caramel.
I've not stirred it or disturbed it
and it just does that.
Caramel's not my friend
at the moment.
Bakers, you are halfway through.
Oh, sorry, you say it.
Bakers, you are halfway through. Yeah.
I've made every single component,
it's now just assembly.
I'm currently lining the moulds
with the joconde sponge.
I decided not to make cube cakes
in a mould because I tried it once at home
and I just found it an absolute nightmare
to get them out.
So I decided to go with the cake frame
and then I can slice them and get them
nice and neat and square at the sides.
Looks pretty good, don't it?
White chocolate bavarois
is now going in.
It's just the assembly.
My stomach's in knots.
Must remember to be neat.
I'm just balling out a hole
in the mousse for the caramel to sit in.
I wanted a gooey centre,
almost have a little bit of a chew.
I'm not cutting the cherries up.
I'll get marked down for that,
but that's how I like it.
It's getting hot again in the tent.
- It is.
- Just in the last ten minutes,
- it's started to get a bit watery.
- It's melting.
- Temperature's creeping up again.
- Yeah.
Ooh, what's that?
- Cherry mousse.
- Ooh.
Yeah, well.
Are you allowing yourself
to think about being in the final yet?
Er, not quite,
'cause there might not be any final
if this doesn't go to plan.
- No, there would still be a final.
- Well, not for me, I mean.
- Not for you.
- That's it.
Do you want us to cancel the final
if you're not in it?
Rinky dink.
Into the freezer we go.
They just need to stay in
as long as possible.
Going pretty good.
Got the raspberry glaze chilling down,
the chocolate glaze is on.
I'm weighing out ingredients
for the pistachio glaze.
More gelatin. This is for my mirror glaze,
so I think there's 24 sheets of gelatin
going into that.
Basically, you'll be able
to see yourself in it.
Mirror glaze is a bit tricky.
I'm not looking forward to it.
I'm preparing the shapes
for my cube cake stand.
I need to make three platforms
and then I need to make some cubes.
I'm a square guy.
I don't know if this is how
it's supposed to look, my mirror glaze.
Oh, it's such a messy business.
Don't think it's supposed
to look this gloopy.
That's the raspberry
mirror glaze complete.
That just has to cool down.
Let's crack on.
Come on. Just this bake
and then it's final.
I know. It's so close.
- How's it going?
- It's all right so far.
This bit always goes fine.
It's just all this assembling...
It's just the judging.
Oh. What a nightmare.
Oh, no, viewers. Where's Noel?
I'm in here.
Huh?
Oh!
- Not really.
- You were there.
Bakers, you have half an hour left.
Yeah, that's not good.
It hasn't set,
but I don't have time,
so I'm gonna keep adding the layers.
I'm just gonna try
and get these out,
get the mirror glaze on. Job's a good 'un.
I'm a bit worried now.
I'm not gonna have the cakes
because they're not gonna set.
Oh, this is gonna take longer
than I thought.
They don't release
very well from these,
so unfortunately, I have to butcher 'em.
Oh.
Happy. It looks good.
Looks really, really good.
Doesn't look quite set inside.
Ah, it's not going too well, is it?
Till you've seen
a man getting cubes
out of a silicone mat, you've not lived.
Do you know how much
each silicone mat costs?
- How much?
- Like, nearly £9.
- £9?
- Yeah.
Who pays for that? Prue?
Yeah, Prue did, yeah.
- I've been sponsored by Prue.
- Have you?
My whole life, yeah.
I walk her dogs.
I shampoo her hair.
Put her husband's waistcoats
in a neat pile.
Get in the wardrobe so they don't see me.
Get sucked into Narnia,
which is a nightmare
'cause it takes about three hours
to get out.
You have to bargain
with some sort of lion king.
It's a disaster, really.
But it's an interesting life,
I wouldn't change it.
Race to the finish.
As usual.
Let's glaze these puppies.
So there's eight in the milk,
eight in the dark and nine in the white.
I've gotta speed up a little bit now.
There's not a lot of time left.
This is just not gonna happen.
Please be good. Please be good.
They looked better without,
didn't they?
Not happy at all with that.
They look a bit jelly-like,
but I might be able to get them out.
This is for the chocolate support.
They look good.
Oh, it's just not staying on.
This is gonna look like a complete mess.
Oh, my God.
I think I've got
a bit too much gelatin.
Don't know if I can glaze those ones.
I honestly don't know
what's happened.
It hasn't gone like this in practice.
What's wrong? Are you okay?
- Don't even wanna carry on.
- Come on.
You can do it. I believe in you.
Bakers, you have ten minutes left.
I think they're looking good.
Is it perfection?
Probably not quite, but it's not far off.
Just keep going. It's good.
It's getting a bit tight so...
Okay.
Oh, dear.
Can't believe I'm done.
Bakers, you have one minute left.
Fit, fit, fit.
Snug as a bug in a rug.
If the mirror glaze had worked,
I would be so proud of these.
Bakers, your time is up.
So upset.
Please step away from your bakes.
Good? Happy?
- Yeah. Are you happy?
- Yeah.
Absolutely gutted.
Oh, that would've looked so good
if that mirror glaze had worked.
How'd it go?
Nightmare. I never had such a disaster.
I've definitely earned my crown
as the messiest, messiest baker.
It's judgement time
for the bakers' showstopping cube cakes.
Dave, would you like to bring up
your showstopper?
- I think they look great.
- Cheers, thank you.
Neat, tidy, uniform.
The chocolate is holding
which is amazing considering the heat.
That was a brave choice.
I like that you made the base, too.
So it looks quite neat.
Mmm.
Look at that caramel in the middle.
Personally, I think they're a triumph.
The caramel is delicious.
It's just the right melting point,
so it oozes, but it still holds.
The mousse is perfectly set.
And the amount of mousse
and filling is quite a lot,
so when you get a mouthful,
it's all fudgy.
Everything together...
- Very good.
- Thank you.
You've improved
a lot actually, David.
Yeah, I think I have, as well.
I feel that I've improved myself.
- Well done.
- Cheers. Thank you.
Well done.
The heat's taken its toll.
It's really difficult
because it's melting,
it looks a little bit messy.
- This is Patisserie Week.
- I know.
- So it's gotta look good.
- I'm so disappointed in the look.
Mmm.
Absolutely delicious.
I love the flavours going through there.
The textures are terrific.
The whole cherries, that was brave,
but it's really delicious.
Not the best you've ever made,
but the flavours are really good.
Worth all the calories.
- Yay!
- Thank you.
Well done, Laura.
- Thanks. You, too.
- Well done.
Thank you.
That is so clever, Peter.
And so complicated.
The overall look is effective
'cause you've got a nice shine
on all of them.
And it's set beautifully.
Sponge and the mousse are gorgeous.
- Mmm.
- Really nice.
I just wanna see what one
of the other one's like.
Let's go for the chocolate one.
It has pistachio mousse
and a raspberry sponge.
Works beautifully.
Can I ask that you try the final one?
It's my favourite.
So that's pistachio cake,
chocolate mousse, raspberry glaze.
Like a sort of friand cake.
- Oh, that one quite disappoints me.
- Oh, no.
Only joking.
- I love them.
- Very clever. Well executed.
- Thank you.
- Well done.
Well done.
- Smashed it.
- Well done, Peter.
Well done, Peter.
Erm, well, it doesn't look great, does it?
No. Not my finest, I'm afraid.
The mousse hasn't quite set here.
The bottom is collapsing
with the weight as it's melting.
But before it melts too much,
let's have a quick look.
That, for me, tastes more like raspberry
than it does cherry.
It's the outside with the raspberry on it,
I love the flavour.
These do feel like panna cotta.
It's really odd.
It's actually quite stodgy and bouncy.
It's got too much gelatin in it.
It's like a rubber ball.
- It's a shame.
- To be honest,
- I'm really disappointed...
- I am, too.
...because you are so good at patisserie
and this is, by your standards,
it's a failure.
I think it goes without saying
I'm really disappointed in myself.
I haven't had any disastrous bake.
This is my first one. It's a shame
that it happened in week nine.
If I do make it to the final,
it would mean a lot.
But it's really 50/50.
I'm happy. Yeah.
It's been a really good week.
Got my first handshake,
first in the technical.
I think I've got a really good
shot for Star Baker.
That was phenomenal.
I am so proud
that I even managed to pull that off.
Paul said it was a triumph.
And that's gonna stick with me forever.
That went
a lot better than expected.
Prue said it was worth the calories.
That's the golden comment
you want from Prue,
so it's gonna be close.
I'm certain it's between
me and Hermine going home.
Hopefully, it'll be enough.
Let's start
with who's had a good week.
I think the lads had a good week.
David and Peter have both done very well.
He struggled from the off.
To come up with that in the semifinal?
Absolutely delicious,
and it's such a sophisticated thing to do.
The other thing
that was really good was Peter's.
I liked the fact that he had
different mousses going in.
Each one, the flavours were amazing.
I would like to give Star Baker
to both those boys.
But what I found so disappointing
is Hermine.
This is Patisserie Week.
It should've been her finest hour, really.
This is basically a rubber ball.
But in her defence,
Hermine made two things.
Laura did one cake.
Doesn't look brilliant,
but when you bit into that,
that was absolutely delicious.
But how many times have we said
Laura's got to save herself
in the showstopper? Five times?
Hermine did have a better technical.
This is a tricky one.
This could go either way.
- Really?
- Yeah.
And this is the worst time
to go out, isn't it?
- It's heartbreaking. You're just there.
- It's brutal.
But that's the position we're in.
Well, it's time for me to tell you
who has been Star Baker this week.
There are a couple of candidates,
but this week's Star Baker is...
Peter.
Well done, Peter.
That leaves me
with the horrible job of announcing
the baker who will be leaving us.
It's especially hard
because the person who's leaving us
is not gonna get to the final,
and you've all been so fantastic
to get this far.
But sadly, there can only be three.
So the person who is leaving us...
is Hermine.
Aw.
- It's been a pleasure.
- It has.
I'm disappointed 'cause, er,
I didn't want to leave.
- Sorry.
- It's fine.
I'm so sorry.
I believe everything has a reason,
and it was the right time for me.
You are so good
and that was just a bad day, wasn't it?
When I go home and I have time to reflect,
there will be, you know,
a lot of happy memories,
a lot of proud moments.
You've been an inspiration,
you really have.
Thank you.
I take a lot of good things
away from this.
Well done for getting Star Baker.
I've hit Bake Off jackpot this week.
You are such a clever lad.
Thank you very much, Prue.
I think it'll take a while to sink in.
It feels a bit surreal.
This whole thing is surreal.
I mean, we're locked down
in a country estate
with Prue Leith and Paul Hollywood
eating your bakes
and Matt Lucas coming round
to make you laugh with Noel.
It's bonkers.
- Congratulations.
- Thanks.
You made the final.
Like, genuinely
I can't process it all right now.
It's mad.
Er, like I'm in the final
of The Great British Bake Off.
Like, the actual final.
Like, yeah. It's, erm...
Maybe it's sinking in a little bit now.
You are flying. Think of that. The final.
I know. Yeah.
Hasn't sunk in yet.
I can't express how happy I am.
It's just unreal. Just can't believe it.
oakislandtk
www.opensubtitles.org